[Music]
pass me a slice please
according to an e.t source after
jennifer lopez and ben affleck said i do
on saturday in las vegas the two
celebrated by enjoying some pizza
together as husband and wife
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time our insider says quote the
newly married couple has kept their
celebrating to a minimum as they plan to
have a bigger gathering within the next
few weeks the marriage in vegas was very
quick once done they had some pizza and
went back to los angeles both have been
married before and wanted to keep the
marriage quiet and low-key before they
plan to have a big celebration in
georgia it's exciting it's exciting etsy
is also learning how jen and ben's exes
and their kids feel about their nuptials
j-lo shares 14 year old twins emmy and
max with marc anthony and ben is the
father of three children violet 16
seraphina 13 and samuel 10 whom he
shares with jennifer garner
according to our source their kids are
feeling more united as a family since
the vegas wedding and they are all super
excited to see what the future holds for
all of them they all get along really
well
as for marc anthony and jennifer garner
they have nothing but support to offer
the newlyweds
quote there is no ill will from anyone
and the mutual goal and focus is zero
to prioritize being great parents to
their children
absolutely speaking of parents according
to the views sunny hostin
jlo's mom apparently knew ben affleck
was the one
on tuesday's episode the co-hosts were
discussing benefit tying the knot in
vegas and that's when sunny revealed she
spoke with jen's mom lupe and she had a
lot to say about the future of their
relationship i've spoken to her mother
lupe about it lupe has always said that
ben is her
true love and we all have them and i
know that this is going to last forever
and they're going to live happily ever
after and that's why she took his last
name and she loves him someone else who
is super excited and supportive of jen
and ben tying the knot is jennifer's
hustler's co-star kiki palmer et spoke
with kiki recently at the premiere of
her film nope where she raved about jen
and ben's big news
i'm so happy jaylon nobody deserves
happiness more you know i think she
works really hard
she's dedicated her life to the industry
she's a woman in power you know it's not
easy for us so i'm just happy for her
yeah